[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est science public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat 90 minutes et deux grands thèmes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité voici
le sommaire de ce premier juin Elisabeth
borne est-elle en sursis recadré par le
Président de la République en conseil
des ministres confrontés à une feuille
de route impossible à mettre en œuvre
fragilisée par son incapacité à dégager
une majorité pour réformer le pays la
première ministre semble sur un siège
éjectable peut-elle surprendre par sa
ténacité réponse juste après ses titres
et puis c'était le 6 mai dernier une
manifestation de groupuscules
identitaire royaliste néo-fasciste
autorisé en plein Paris
je conçois que ces images aient pu
choquées et simplement je rappelle que
dans notre pays il y a un droit à
manifester qui est garantie et qu'on ne
peut
revenir sur ce droit que quand il y a
des bonnes raisons qui sont énumérées
dans la loi des images qui ont fait
ressorties le terme d'ultra-droite dans
les médias moi plus tard on va débattre
de l'attractivité de ces mouvements
souvent violents de leurs liens avec le
rassemblement national ils existent
encore et des menaces qui font peser sur
nos démocraties mais d'abord à mi-chemin
des 100 jours donnés à Elizabeth borne
pour élargir sa majorité ou en est la
locataire de Matignon avant de donner la
parole à nos experts c'est Cécile sigsu
qui ouvre le débat
il y en avoir si Emmanuel Macron a
recadré Elisabeth borne après ses propos
sur le RN tout va bien entre les deux
têtes de l'exécutif c'est en tout cas le
message que font passer les deux
intéressés la première ministre assure
avoir une relation fluide avec le
président de son côté manuel Macron
affiche publiquement sa confiance en
elle madame la Première ministre je veux
ici lui redire toute ma confiance et je
savais j'ai eu un mode de fonctionnement
simple quand j'ai des choses à dire les
premiers ministres depuis 6 ans je le
dis dans un colloque singulier dont rien
ne sort
et nous réglons les choses ensemble cet
épisode n'est pas le premier au sein du
couple exécutif et il fragilise la
première ministre selon le sénateur
écologiste Guillaume Gontard j'aimerais
pas être à la place Elisabeth clairement
puisque à la fois justement l'absence
l'absence de cap l'absence de
perspective le fait de se faire recadrer
par un président de la République qui
est je dirais à la fois présent quand il
devrait plutôt se mettre en retrait et
absent quand on voudrait plutôt la voir
et on l'a vu sur la sur la réforme des
retraites je pense que effectivement
elle a une tâche qui n'est pas facile
alors après pas facile non plus pour
Elisabeth borne de tenir la feuille de
route confiée par le Président de la
République à savoir élargir sa majorité
en son jour le sénateur rouge et karucci
estime même que cette émission
impossible je ne vois pas bien
en quoi les 100 jours en question
pourrait être entre guillemets réussi
alors à mon sens ça n'était pas faisable
lorsque le président de la République a
donné cette feuille de route
il devait parfaitement être conscient
que ça ne tiendrait pas ni en 100 jours
ni dans le projet sans confiance du
président ni majorité à l'Assemblée
l'avenir de la première ministre
pourrait être compromis des difficultés
qui attisent des ambitions au sein du
gouvernement ou les quoique se
multiplient entre ministre le Val des
prétendants l'avenir des réformes le
fonctionnement du binôme Macron borne
voilà autant de thèmes passionnants pour
ce premier débat avec Bérengère Bonte
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
à France Info auteur de cette biographie
Elisabeth borne la secrète publiée aux
éditions de l'archipel emyzapalski
bonsoir Émilie bienvenue à vous vous
êtes communiquante fondatrice et
directrice de l'agence Émilie conseil
Frédéric David bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
Frédéric le directeur général opinion de
l'Ifop et Mathilde Sirault bonsoir
Mathilde heureux de vous retrouver sur
ce plateau vous êtes éditorialiste
politique pour sens publique allez une
première question assez générale est-ce
que vous pensez qu'ils avaient de borne
étant sursis Bérenger bon moi je ne
crois pas
je pense je me pose beaucoup de
questions sur cette ce recadrage ou
pseudo recadrage qui sent le la en
partie ou en totalité l'opération deux
comme assez assez complexe de de jeux
pas très simple qui arrange les uns les
autres pour avoir précédemment enquêter
sur le Conseil des ministres très
longuement j'avais fait au moins trois
ou quatre éditions d'une longue enquête
sur toute la Cinquième République
c'est un sport national de faire des
fausses fuites de dire qu'un tel c'est
faire cadrer par le Président c'est
qu'on pourrir par l'autre etc donc
prudence quoi vraiment
et on reparlera notamment de
la réalité des recadrage par le passé en
tout cas ce moment là il faut être très
prudent
est-ce qu'il a intérêt on reste sur ce
thème là Emmanuel Macron a séparé sa
première ministre en tout cas maintenant
à s'en séparés il peut l'utiliser encore
un petit peu longtemps comme on dit
toujours fusible mais en tout cas elle
prend beaucoup hein sur cet échec à ne
pas réussir à avoir une majorité cet
échec à faire avancer les dossiers
l'immigration enfin il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qui se passent et
finalement c'est comme un faire valoir
finalement Elizabeth borne tant qu'elle
est un petit peu raide qu'elle peut
supporter ses échecs là lui ça lui donne
l'occasion de briller rayonner c'est ce
qu'il a essayé de faire depuis le 49-3
il a essayé de passer à plein de sujets
finalement il a plutôt réussi parce que
même si on continue en temps un peu
parler des casseroles mais vraiment pas
beaucoup on est passé à d'autres sujets
on sent que la réforme des retraites
commence à être un peu derrière même si
certains n'ont pas oublié notamment sur
le fameux déni de démocratie ça ça
restera probablement mais en tout cas
j'ai l'impression que elle elle est
techno elle est triste et lui brille à
côté je pense qu'il a intérêt à jouer de
ça encore longtemps et puis après la
question c'est de savoir qui mettrait à
la place et je pense que ça serait
encore très long à déterminer et à
trouver une personnalité et à savoir
tout de suite on en parlera du mal des
prétendants évidemment dans une Afrique
d'habits comment les les Français
perçoivent elisab mais ça on a déjà pas
mal répondu à cette question mais
surtout son avenir à Matignon c'est une
question que les Français ne se posent
absolument pas
chaque mois 2000 Verbatim de français
satisfaite d'après un ministre à 28 %
mécontent ils ont une grille d'analyse
politique d'évaluation sur l'action
est-ce que son action change la vie qui
était elle a une image personnelle qui
est plutôt favorable mais la question de
son départ ne se pose pas j'ai envie de
dire en étant peut-être méchant la
question des Français le problème ce
n'est pas Madame borne pour une majorité
de Français le problème c'est Emmanuel
Macron c'est la solution pour son socle
et il a connu un petit regain de
popularité en parlant de nouveau avec
ces déplacements la très forte présence
sur la saturation médiatique à son socle
mais ce n'est absolument pas le départ
des headband et d'ailleurs par rapport
au recadrage avec des gros guillemets
l'impact sur l'opinion je vous fiche mon
billet en étant un peu trivial qu'il va
être absolument nul traditionnellement
les
parce que il ne y voit le couple
exécutif comme un bloc j'avais été
frappé dans nos enquêtes qualitatives en
mai juin 2020 quand le Tout-Paris le
microcosme Bruxelles de de coude grisou
de de tension entre Édouard Philippe et
Emmanuel Macron ceux qui sortait c'était
un couple exécutif uni dans le contexte
covid j'ai même regardé il y a quelques
jours les Verbatim de Mitterrand Rocard
on avait parlé de cohabitation bises on
ne parlait que de tension ou pas de
attention sachant que Mitterrand louait
dans les médias très souvent et très
régulièrement son premier ministre ça ne
sortait absolument pas parce que ce
n'est pas la question que les Français
se posent ils sont plutôt sur
l'évaluation de l'action l'image plus
que des tensions éventuelles et je leur
ai je le répète l'avenir de la première
ministre c'était pas une question que
les français évoquent ouvertement elle
est à 28% de satisfaire dans votre
dernier baromètre pour le JDD dont vous
parliez c'est corrélé avec la popularité
du prénom République il y a pas de
décalage un niveau ce qui est très
intéressant de noter c'est qu'elle a
chuté avant le président puisqu'elle
chute en octobre novembre avec un effet
49-3 au moment des 8 9 49-3 sur le débat
budgétaire alors qu'Emmanuel Macron ça
clairement été la réforme des retraites
et la méthode autour de cette réforme
mais on a des popularités qui sont
relativement corrélés rien à voir avec
des popularités de distinction François
Fillon populaire pendant 5 ans
chroniqueur à Sarkozy ne l'était pas et
puis les 40 points d'écart en 2014-2015
entre François Hollande d'un côté
Emmanuel Valls on est vraiment sur un
coup d'exécutif qui a une communauté de
destin s'agissant des popularité alors
on prend les pincettes évidemment sur ce
recadrage en tout cas c'était manuel
Macron qui a relancé la machine à doute
peut-être volontairement effectivement
qui est qui sait on va on va pouvoir
l'analyser tout commence par cette
interview d'Elizabeth borne chez nos
confrères de radiologie on leur écoute
c'est moi je le crois pas du tout à la
normalisation du rassemblement national
je pense qu'il faut pas banaliser ses
idées ses idées sont toujours les mêmes
alors maintenant
rassemblement national il met les formes
mais je pense continuer à penser que
c'est une idéologie dangereuse
Marie Le Pen pareil je pense que je n'ai
jamais entendu Marine Le Pen dénoncer ce
qu'on puisse être les positions
historiques de son de son parti et je
pense que un changement de nom ne change
pas les idées des racines et donc deux
jours plus tard à la table du Conseil
des ministres le chef de l'État affirme
qu'il ne faut pas combattre l'extrême
droite en employant je le cite des
arguments moraux juge éculés donc il a
des menti ensuite visé sa première
ministre aujourd'hui on l'a dit dans le
sujet
Elisabeth borne parle d'une relation
très fluide avec le président de la
République tout va bien
oui moi ça me fait penser on parlait je
vais tout dire à nos téléspectateurs on
parlait sport juste avant que ce débat
de démarre en général quand un président
de club dit que son entraîneur est super
et qu'il a confiance en lui bon il se
passe des choses derrière bref ça vaut
pas peut-être
qui sont sortis c'est une chose et puis
il y a la façon dont ça s'est fait et
c'est là où il y a une surenchère
probablement un truc un peu monté en
épingle il a regardé dans les yeux et
donc autour de la table on a senti de
l'attention ou pas c'est là où il y a où
il y a un doute que ça peut être
d'autres des prétendants éventuels qui
font fuiter ça volontairement national
ça oui d'accord
c'est vraiment l'exercice et c'est vrai
que c'est vrai qu'il a il a quand même
multiplié de les sorties récemment dans
la presse au détour comme ça d'interview
des des j'espère qu'elle y arrivera
j'aurais dû plus m'impliquer
c'est une réforme mal expliquée bon donc
en fait il y a une différence pour
certains à bien forcer le trait
maintenant peut-être que ça c'est
réellement fait si c'est le cas c'est
vraiment vraiment on va dire un piètre
manager et puis une étrange stratégie
vis-à-vis pardon mais du du
rassemblement national parce que au bout
du compte c'est quand même un cadeau
incroyable qui sont en train de faire là
au rassemblement national alors ça c'est
intéressant et mise à parce que c'est
révélateur de de différence d'analyses
ou de stratégies sur le rassemblement
national entre finalement la première
ministre et le président de la
République en tout cas ça fait plusieurs
mois qu'il y a moi j'appelle ça des
ambiguïtés en fait de la part de la
majorité et notamment d'Emmanuel Macron
sur le rassemblement national une espèce
de façon d'aller un petit peu draguer
peut-être tout doucement ces électeurs
de droite dur et éventuellement
d'extrême droite moi je pense que ça a
commencé au soir du premier tour des
législatives parce que souvenez-vous il
y a pas eu des consignes clairs qui ont
été donnés rapidement justement sur ce
front républicain qu'il appelle pourtant
à chaque fois de ses vœux pour être élu
et ça a mis beaucoup de temps au point
que par exemple des clés Mambo n'avaient
été obligé de dire bah moi
personnellement voilà les consignes que
je vais donner vis-à-vis du
rassemblement national et puis tout d'un
coup évidemment avec avec un petit peu
les réactions il y a eu ce
positionnement on voit quand même un
Bruno Le Maire ministre de l'Économie
quand même purement gaulliste qui parle
de la fraude sociale qui s'évade au
Maghreb moi j'ai été très choquée parce
que jamais j'ai entendu un Bruno Le
Maire dire ça Darmanin chez Darmanin
c'est peut-être plus habituel mais on
sent quand même la rhétorique qui est
utilisée aussi par Emmanuel Macron la
décibilisation même si on a dit que oui
c'était pas ça que c'était un sociologue
mais quand même c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui sait très bien utiliser
son vocabulaire il le fait pas comme ça
par un pur hasard je trouve qu'il y a
beaucoup de signaux qui sont donnés sur
ça et le fait de dire que on utilise
plus des arguments des années 90
d'accord pour les jeunes parce que
peut-être que les jeunes n'ont pas les
mêmes références d'abord ils sont pas
d'accord dans son camp comme on l'a vu
avec Bruno Le Maire qui a réagi à ça
Clément bon aussi qui a réagi sur Pétain
et sur l'idée de revenir sur l'histoire
ils sont pas d'accord entre eux ok pour
la jeunesse peut-être qu'il faut parler
autrement mais il faut quand même y
aller et on a l'impression qu'ils y vont
très timidement ça nous fait un lien
avec le thème de notre second débat
parce qu'on va parler des des
groupuscules d'extrême on va dire hors
Parlement
cette formulation finalement que reprend
Elizabeth borne puisque c'est les
journalistes héritiers de Pétain dit
hériter le Pétain ou absolument est-ce
que vous êtes vous d'accord avec
Emmanuel Macron qui dit que c'est un peu
caduc ou éculé j'ai pas à être pas
d'accord c'est vrai que dans l'analyse
de l'Union on a vu historiquement des
des temps très différents
sur l'explication de la montée du vote
eren et sur l'éruption c'était il y a
une quarantaine d'années les élections
municipales n'ont pas à Dreux mais à
Paris 20e avec un bon score de
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui avait fait 11 et
demi pour cent c'était oui c'était quand
même une association moins de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale que avec l'Algérie
française l'os le poujadisme et puis
c'est vrai que ce rappel des amitiés
entre Jean-Marie Le Pen et un fan SS
France schönüberg était pas Amand du
Front national mais qui était le
représentant de la partie d'extrême
droite allemande il y avait souviens des
leaders de gauche du PC du Best qui
refusait de débattre avec lui donc il y
a eu d'abord une une sorte de
délégitimation historique puis il y a eu
un doublement il y a eu l'excuse des
électeurs du rassemble du Front national
de l'époque il se posent il se posait
vrai question la phrase de Laurent
Fabius sur le FN qui apporte des bons
constats et des mauvaises solutions le
contre-exemple c'est le la fameuse
phrase de Bernard Tapie avec son son
analogie puisque Le Pen est un
ces électeurs sont des mais
aujourd'hui que voit-on dans les
enquêtes d'opinion on voit quand même
que les arguments que j'appellerai pas
Moro mais des arguments historiques de
délégitimation d'un camp ne fonctionne
absolument pas qu'est-ce qui me fait
dire ça ce sont les deux grandes
enquêtes qu'on a faites en 2017 et 2021
qui s'appelait radoscopie du vote FN et
RN on voit très bien que sur les
motivations du vote RN chez des
électeurs l'argument moral ne joue pas
l'image de Marine Le Pen est extrêmement
faible comme levier de vote alors ça va
peut-être changer c'est pas qu'on refera
cette prochainement mais c'est d'abord
le vote rnfn c'est de plus en plus un
vote 2 d'adhésion puisque un vote de
protestation et les deux leviers qui
expliquent alors c'est une
reconstruction le vote et Rennes chez
ses électeurs c'est il fait des constats
justes sur l'état de la société une
forme de Cassandre qui avait utilisé
aussi un vrai levier du vote Zemmour et
il propose des solutions efficaces sur
des questions immigration en sécurité
donc on est pas du tout sur l'historique
et pas du tout sur les arguments bon
alors tout le monde veut prendre la
parole mais je veux rapidement parce que
on va ensuite revenir si on est sur le
RN il faut pas que je mange trop mon
second débat Bérengère et ensuite un
petit point sur Elisabeth quand elle
quand elle prononce ses mots à
radiologie radiologie bien sûr et elle
fit de déporter avec l'histoire qu'elle
a géré il faut forcément il faut
évidemment avoir ça en tête on peut
s'interroger sur son positionnement et
idéologique je le fais dans le bouquin
mais s'il y a bien une chose sur
laquelle elle est quand même très très
claire et et c'est les tripes qui parle
c'est le le combat contre le contre
l'extrême droite et il y a une notion
d'histoire quel incarne d'une certaine
façon je veux dire ce qui dont elle a
dit dans sa déclaration politique
générale qui n'était jamais tout à fait
revenue des camps qui se qui se
suicident quand à la 11 ans c'est
quelque chose qui est tellement
tellement ancré dans les dans les tripes
que vraiment il faut l'avoir il faut
l'avoir en tête donc qu'elle ait envie
de faire œuvre de mémoire et qu'elle
rappelle notamment aux jeunes électeurs
du rassemblement national qui a cette
composante historique ça me paraît
évident je pense que c'est aussi le
résultat de cette stratégie magnifique
de communication du Front national
devenu rassemblement national qui a donc
mis des habits très jolis pour déguiser
l'intérieur c'est de plus en plus
difficile de les considérer comme
extrême droite mais je pense que la
lutte ne doit pas se terminer et après
il y a la lutte concrète contre leur
mesure auquel s'attache aussi
connaissance entre le contenu on va dire
des programmes alors je reviens au
binôme Emmanuel Macron Elisabeth borne
et je propose à Tam être à lui de nous
rejoindre qu'on parlait recadrage ou pas
recadrage bonsoir Tam bienvenu c'est pas
exactement le premier depuis les
retraites rien ne va plus le précédent
en tout cas que l'on a interprété comme
telle date de début avril depuis la
Chine le président de la République
répond vertement au syndicat il ni qu'il
y ait une quelconque crise démocratique
en France il juge même qu'il a eu un
mandat clair pour faire la réforme des
retraites bref il reste droit dans ses
bottes et voilà qui Isabelle bordel joue
une toute autre partition c'est la carte
de l'apaisement dans un entretien au
Monde à l'appel je la cite à respecter
une période de convalescence avec les
syndicats pour qu'ils ne sortent pas de
l'âge de la site encore humilié en fin
dans le même entretien dit ne pas être
là simplement pour administrer le pays
réponse de l'entourage d'Emmanuel Macron
le président de la République coordonne
avec la première ministre le cap a été
donné par le Président de la République
et forcément toute la presse se fait
l'écho de friture sur la ligne Élisée
Matignon et depuis le dossier de
l'immigration n'a pas arrangé les choses
oui cette loi sans cesse annoncée depuis
un an et reporter tout autant on se
rappelle qu'Emmanuel Macron avait aussi
donné pour mission Elisabeth borne
d'élargir la majorité Elisabeth borne
avait répondu plutôt majorité texte par
texte pour l'instant car l'élargissement
de la majorité à anne-marceron pour
l'instant nous ne voyons rien venir et
bien c'est bien l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles Emmanuel Macron et Isabelle
borne ne sont pas du tout sur le même
tempo sur le dossier immigration
Emmanuel Macron mi-avril si la loi ne
passe pas avant l'été elle ne passera
pas du tout trois jours plus tard
Elisabeth borne pas de texte immigration
avant l'automne car nous n'avons pas de
majorité et finalement le 10 mai et bien
on apprend qu'un texte sera présenté
avant l'été la première ministre et son
gouvernement doivent désormais se
débrouiller pour bâtir une majorité sur
ce texte ce n'est pas simple on l'a vu
le résultat c'est que lorsque ce n'est
pas fluide dans le couple exécutif et
bien plus personne n'y comprend grand
chose alors que pour que peut-on dire de
l'état de la relation entre Elisabeth
borne et Emmanuel Macron parce qu'on
peut dire c'est qu'on ne peut déjà pas
du tout compter sur Emmanuel Macron pour
nous le dire dans un entretien à
challenge il a très brièvement répondu
et beauté en touche quand lui est posé
la question voilà de la réponse la
réponse c'est j'ai une règle qui n'a
jamais été démenti je n'ai jamais parlé
de mes premiers ministres je pense que
c'est sacro-saint dans la 5ème
république notre relation est de
confiance service minimum et très loin
des mots qu'il a vécu pour Jean Castex
prof qu'il avait aussi parlé de ses
premiers ministres il avait qualifié de
Premier ministre exceptionnel juste à la
fin du premier quinquennage en castexte
qui lorsqu'il avait eu des débuts
chahutés à Matignon en se rappelle avait
pu compter sur Emmanuel Macron qui avait
alors déclaré le Premier ministre
quelqu'un de très expérimenté il agit
avec une sincérité un engagement
remarquable comme Édouard Philippe avant
lui et doit Philippe avait eu aussi
droit à des compliments et un recadrage
d'Emmanuel Macron au mois de mai 2020 il
avait parlé alors le premier ministre de
l'époque de risque d'écroulement du pays
Emmanuel Macron avait dit je n'emploie
pas ses grands mots de mois plus tard il
devait s'aider sa place merci beaucoup
thème pour pour ce rappel qui était
passionnant Bérengère bon vous avez
aussi écrit une biographie de d'Édouard
Philippe est-ce que vous diriez
qu'Emmanuel Macron se comporte
différemment avec Elisabeth borne que
dans son binôme précédent et que Édouard
Philippe officiellement tout allait bien
et le le rappel la de ce qui s'était
passé en mai il faut on était vraiment
au bout de 3 ans déjà mais
officiellement il y avait comme il
disait pas l'épaisseur de d'un papier à
cigarette de différence entre nous
officiellement c'était comme ça et sans
doute que ça fonctionnait pas si mal en
vérité c'est pour ça que moi j'appelle
je suis toujours très prudente sur ce
qu'on ce que les uns et les autres
prétendent savoir franchement qui peut
probablement une guéguerre entre les
entourages c'est évident et c'est là
c'est ça qui donne aussi les les échos
dans la presse
commun mais je veux dire il y a voilà il
y a des rivalités pour moi elles sont au
moins autant là alors est-ce qu'il s'est
comporté différemment je suis quand même
obligé de vous dire que un diabète est
une femme
je veux pas dire que c'est le seul
élément mais il y a quelque chose
il y a souvent des échos quand même
d'une attitude d'Emmanuel Macron qui est
quand même allez est-ce qu'on peut dire
macho un peu quand même hein et il y a
une dureté bon est-ce que c'est toujours
vrai qu'il est assez peu entouré de
enfin beaucoup entourés d'hommes dans
son bien sûr
la secrétaire général elle est à
Matignon claire-landais mais sinon à
l'Elysée oui ce sont ce sont beaucoup
des hommes
non moi je suis quand même assez
interloqué par la phrase d'Emmanuel
Macron je ne parle jamais de mes
premiers ministres c'est en rupture
totale avec peut-être un peu sa pratique
on a donné l'exemple de Jean Castex mais
c'est en rupture avec tout ce qu'on fait
les présidents qui ont vu dans leur
premier ministre un atout Giscard
d'Estaing Raymond Barre est le meilleur
économiste de France il avait de la même
manière loué Jacques Chirac en public en
disant j'espère que vous rester pendant
tout mon septennat c'est l'idée dans les
conférences de presse dans des grands
moments des us et coutumes
présidentielles on a vu des présidents
et on les journalistes pointaient qui
est-il cité non pas comme prémices mais
comme ministre pour les valoriser les
citations
tu utilises le jeu non le prénom ou pas
exactement et là on voit très bien qu'il
est alors ça peut accréditer le soupçon
de pouvoir personnel donc ce sont qui
est plus fortement relayé chez les
Français de quelqu'un de très seul qui
n'écoute pas l'absence d'écoute c'est
une critique qui est devenue majeure
dans la perception qu'on les Français et
c'est les faire retraite bien sûr
d'email Macron il a pas écouté la
rouille est manifestants les syndicats
les oppositions voir les enquêtes
d'opinion qui montraient le rejet à
l'égard de la réforme des retraites donc
ça peut être c'est très intéressant la
manière dont ils n'en parle pas même si
je le répète l'impact sur l'opinion et
on va recommander chose et quand même
très marginal sur le bloc président
féministe nous c'est pas grave on parle
à des passionné de politique dans cette
émission va-t-il
Édouard Philippe puis-je en Castex puis
Elisabeth borne il faut rappeler quand
même les conditions de nomination
d'Élisabeth borne qui sont particulières
puisque d'ailleurs Ludovic vigogne a
très bien raconté dans son livre Les 100
jours quand Emmanuel Macron
pense à son premier ministre pour son
second quinquennat d'abord il veut
nommer Catherine Vautrin donc Elisabeth
borne c'est son plan B par défaut parce
qu'il a eu un tir de barrage de ses
proches dans la majorité qui ne voulait
pas en fait d'une XLR qui avait été et
qui était opposé au mariage pour tous et
donc il s'est retrouvé à à nommer
Isabelle borde parce qu'en plus il lui
fallait une femme donc il y a toutes ces
conditions là ce contexte de départ qui
déjà ne favorise pas un lien
Emmanuel Macron je vais être un peu
trial tapé dans la main de Catherine
Vautrin quoi sur le langage Matignon
alors c'est là aussi c'est aussi dans
votre vie pardon mais moi je me suis
permise aussi de dézoomer puisque je
fais la il y a 62 années de la ville
d'isabeth bandé et en fait si on revient
un an on arrive
un petit coup de pub en septembre donc
un an un an avant dans la dernière
édition quinquennat il y a quand même un
certain nombre de gens dans la gauche de
la majorité qui commence vraiment à
faire campagne pour elle et elle y
compris pas commencer à rentrer dans
donc dans cette hypothèse de travail de
longue haleine c'était finalement le
plan a en vérité vraiment et c'est
quelque chose qui qui en se disant on
aura besoin d'un renfort de ce qui a un
petit peu de quelqu'un
je me souviens que l'un des premiers
noms cités ça avait été solidaire des
avais demandé avant d'être balayé pour
que on se finalement d'autres non
qui qui tendent le bras d'Emmanuel
Macron si je peux me permettre le
dernier le fameux dernier week-end ou
finalement il décide que ce ne sera pas
Catherine Beaurain ce sont les mêmes qui
un an plus tôt commençait à alimenter
l'hypothèse l'hypothèse-borde et ce qui
est intéressant aussi à comprendre entre
les deux peut-être Emmanuel Macron et
Isabelle bande c'est que quand même on
tout à l'heure il n'écoute pas il l'a
écouté au début et quand même elle a
elle elle est parvenue à le convaincre
de reporter cette fameuse réforme des
retraites de se donner plus de temps de
de là il y avait des il y avait des
éléments un peu technique mais quand
même il l'a écouté un certain nombre de
fois et moi ça me donne l'impression un
peu d'une volonté de là de de rappeler
le patron quoi en fait c'est très très
la question du management quoi
alors qu'il y avait ça ça a l'air de ça
avait l'air de plutôt bien fonctionner
moi pour en avoir discuté et avec elle
et avec son directeur de cabinet et avec
pas mal de gens déconseillés etc à un
moment vous moi j'arrive à un tableau
qui qui fonctionnait plutôt bien au
début et où elle elle emportait
l'affaire comme elle l'a toujours
emporté dans tout son parcours c'est
elle est stupéfiant non il y a vraiment
une question de management de ressources
humaines ça on l'a dit beaucoup chez
Emmanuel Macron ils sont mouvements mais
aussi de management parce que regardez
Édouard Philippe alors oui il l'a
encensé et puis finalement il a pas
supporté qui brille beaucoup plus que
lui quand il avait cette popularité
fameuse bah du coup il le met dehors
genre l'histoire de la 5e République
c'est rare sont les présidents qu'on
supportait
Emmanuel Macron parce que son mouvement
est nouveau il a eu du mal il a du mal
quand même à faire monter des figures
regardez à part Bruno Le Maire Gérald
Darmanin peut-être Eric Dupond-Moretti
et lui-même s'en est moqué quand il dit
c'est vrai que pour Christophe Béchu bon
pas grand monde le connaissent le
connaît il a du mal à faire monter des
personnalités il a peur probablement
qu'on lui fasse de l'ombre en tout cas
ne supporte pas ça il est partout sur
tous les dossiers il grille quasiment
tous ces ministres d'ailleurs je parlais
de Christophe Béchu là tout d'un coup il
est sur youtube il va annoncer plein de
mesures c'est quand même monsieur Boula
facette qui prend non mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il a besoin de la
lumière il a besoin dans les images bon
monsieur il a besoin de la lumière et du
coup il a du mal à faire monter des
personnalités et quand elles sont trop
brillantes il a du mal à les supporter
en concurrence très brièvement moi c'est
pendant l'enquête une des choses et une
des raisons pour laquelle ce bouquin
s'appelle la secrète c'est qu'il y a
aussi une forme de secret sur ses
ambitions personnelles
préparer une présidentielle mais en
revanche moi le cabinet m'a appelé en
disant vous pouvez arrêter de dire
demander à tout le monde si elle a des
ambitions présidentielles comme si cette
fallait surtout dire quoi il y avait
vraiment une crainte que ça puisse
remonter à Emmanuel Macron c'est comme
ça que je le comprenais comme et qu'elle
apparaisse comme une concurrente qu'elle
ne voulait pas être alors qu'elle a de
l'ambition évidemment elle est un
des experts le gouvernement où il y a
peu de ministres qui incarne on peut
citer quand même Gabriel Attal que le
ministre qui était complètement inconnu
en 2019 qui est vraiment maintenant qui
est parmi les et Olivier vérans ce qui
sont parmi les ministres les plus
populaires c'était d'abord un choix
volontaire du président Macron en 2017
pour créer la rupture à distinction avec
l'échec des professionnels de la
politique sous Sarkozy et souffrances
Hollande être sur un gouvernement des
experts répondre à un imaginaire des
Français ont mis une sportive au sport
un DRH un emploi etc la surprise c'est
qu'il est continué en 2022 alors que
maintenant les Français veulent de
l'Incarnation quand on voit les sujets
que les inquiète le plus en dehors de
l'inflation et du poids d'achat santé
éducation grand âge logement et ben ce
sont des ministres qui sont très peu
connus des français connu par une
minorité ce qui complique évidemment la
tâche de la première ministre c'est
cette feuille de route impossible donnée
par le présent République les fameux 100
jours sur ce thème je vous propose
d'écouter en longueur parce qu'on a eu
un court extrait dans le dans notre
reportage d'ouverture Roger caoutchi
sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine le texte sur
les migration d'une espèce d'art lésier
dont on n'arrive pas à savoir si au
final ils vont y arriver ou pas
on voit des désaccords très net entre
Gérald Darmanin et Elizabeth borne et
probablement l'Élysée
ça n'avance pas sur le texte sur les
textes sociaux notamment sur les textes
concernant le partage de la valeur
travail etc ça bouge peu ça n'évolue pas
donc je ne vois pas bien
en quoi les 100 jours en question
pourrait être entre guillemets réussi
alors à mon sens ça n'était pas faisable
lorsque le président de la République a
donné cette feuille de route
il devait parfaitement être conscient
j'en parle alors elle adorait aller voir
ça avec son fils au cinéma quand il
était plus jeune mais encore aujourd'hui
et il y a l'idée de sauver le pays de
sauver le monde de de réparer le pays
comme elle dit et quand on regarde en
fait son son parcours moi je j'imaginais
qu'elle lance comme ça ces élastiques et
en fait parce que parce qu'elle a passé
son temps à après
voilà c'est un peu ça c'est comment
rejoindre les les contraires et essayer
de créer une majorité là voilà elle crée
une majorité là où il y en a pas quoi tu
es sans doute de ce point de vue là il y
a il y a par ailleurs beaucoup de
rigidité dans dans le personnage et dans
même dans sa morphologie donc c'est très
étonnant mais mais en tout cas c'est son
héroïne ouais Frédéric Daby on est à
mi-chemin là des des 100 jours et
effectivement moi on peut reprendre les
le constat fait par Roger caoutchi on
voit pas les chantiers annoncés par le
président République
avancer aussi vite que prévu quoi ou
alors c'était ou alors c'était injuste
un coup de com mais est-ce que c'est une
stratégie ou c'était un coup tactique
l'idée des 100 jours et de cette
intervention présidentielle c'était
l'idée de sortir du tout retraite des
accès l'agenda des Français qui était
retraites retraites retraite alors même
que la loi a été votée au Fiat 49.3
alors qu'elle a été validée par le
Conseil constitutionnel donc se donner
comment dire du temps c'était essayer de
de réinjecter d'autres d'autres enjeux
on l'a vu quand le président annoncé
lui-même son plan sur les lycées
professionnels il a pas les pouvoirs il
a commencé saturer l'espace médiatique
mais est-ce que les Français ont acheté
cette ce côté moyen terme 100 jours j'ai
envie de dire non parce que c'est pas
leur sujet leur sujet c'est que le
politique change la vie c'est que
Emmanuel Macron puisse
sortir de la question des retraites et
améliore leur quotidien c'est je trouve
quand même que il a réussi
à moitié il a réussi parce que dans les
enquêtes de popularité même si ils
progresse légèrement dans son socle
c'est-à-dire personne âgées quatre
supérieures sont électorat il a vraiment
connu un véritable rebond mais en dehors
de cela pour l'instant ça bouge pas
beaucoup et puis je le répète et ça peut
apparaître étonnant même si ça va être
qu'on parle moins des casseroles on a
publié une enquête ce matin avec le JDD
ou le niveau de soutien au moment social
du 6 juin reste majoritaire mais en
baisse de 10 points par rapport à un
mois les Français sont pas complètement
sortis de ce coup de la semaine
prochaine et bien manifestation puis
réactiver les choses la proposition de
loi du groupe pilote même si elle a été
on va dire pour l'instant vider voilà
ratiboiser moi je suis pas sûr qu'en
termes de communication en effet ça soit
grave qui est pas de bilan ou 100 jours
il a voulu montrer qu'il avançait que on
continuait ou quoi ce qui est plus grave
et à mon avis
le bilan
il y a aussi cette idée d'impasse et
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on voit avec
Elisabeth borne c'est-à-dire OK les 100
jours mais alors après de toute façon si
on peut pas faire passer de loi si on
fait que du réglementaire si on n'a pas
de perspective et ça je pense que les
Français le sentent et se désintéressent
peut-être un peu d'ailleurs des discours
politiques parce que ils se sentent vidé
de tout ça il y a pas de perspective
pour les 4 ans à venir est-ce que Émilie
le l'élargissement de la majorité
pourrait se faire grâce à la loi
immigration alors là c'est mal parti
c'est mal parti quand même parce que les
propositions de loi proposer par les
républicains ils sont quand même assez
radical moi j'admire l'élasticité
d'Elizabeth borne parce que on sent que
c'est pas du tout dans son orientation
de tels d'aller si loin sur le plan
radical et d'aller courir encore une
fois sur des plates bandes du
rassemblement national je suis pas sûr
que ça soit là après il peut y avoir des
surprises aussi pourquoi pas imaginer
que l'élargissement se fasse autrement
je pense qu'il y a bon c'est peut-être
mon rêve qui se mélange avec la réalité
mais on sait que en effet sur l'écologie
enfin vous l'avez pas cité tout à
l'heure dans les préoccupations mais ça
devient quand même
quelque chose qui est de plus en plus
dans la société est-ce que il pourrait
pas un peu aussi se questionner là
dessus et pas toujours tirer à droite à
droite à droite ou alors ça veut dire
que véritablement c'est la fin du en
même temps et clairement il se situe à
droite il pactisent avec les
républicains quitte à aller encore
chercher des électeurs chez Zemmour chez
le rassemblement national et c'est tout
c'est la Nouvelle Droite d'Emmanuel
Macron alors cette question va se la
poser aussi avec vous Mathilde puisque
on le dit depuis le début de ce débat
c'est pas la question est-ce qu'elle est
fragilisée ou pas et ça relance les
spéculations sur les prétendants à
Matignon alors depuis qu'elle a été
nommée et compte tenu des conditions
politiques de l'instabilité créée par la
majorité relative en réalité c'est
spéculations sont constantes alors avant
de se lancer dans cette liste des
candidats ou des successeurs potentiels
une question de préexiste Emmanuel
Macron souhaite-il changer la nature de
sa gouvernance et faire évoluer sa
conception du rôle de son premier
ministre on l'a vu il a il apprécie les
qui forcément n'ont pas forcément de
surface politique au démarrage alors à
l'évidence il n'a pas forcément envie de
changer cette méthode il a dit que sur
les retraites il aurait dû davantage
mouiller le maillot il veut continuer
lui-même à piloter et à donner
l'impulsion et donc se préalable élimine
a priori d'emblée l'hypothèse de
nomination de personnalités politiques
fortes on pense par exemple à Bruno Le
Maire à François Bayrou ou même à Gérald
Darmanin donc le scénario Matignon est
donc compromis d'autant plus pour ces
trois là pourquoi parce qu'il
nourrissent évidemment des ambitions
présidentielles et puis on l'évoquait à
l'instant il y a aussi cette question
qui reste quand même d'une coalition ou
non avec la droite pour évidemment
stabiliser sa majorité Emmanuel Macron
pourrait avoir la possibilité de nouer
une alliance du côté de sa droite là où
des personnalités se disent plutôt
prêtes à travailler avec lui sous
certaines conditions c'est l'option
Gérard Larcher par exemple mais plutôt
dans un calendrier post-élection
sénatoriale c'est fin septembre mais là
encore ça supposer pour le président de
la République de céder une part de son
de son pouvoir ou en tout cas de revoir
quelque peu son projet politique ce
qu'il ne semble ne sont pas du tout
prêts à aller vers cela on entend aussi
par exemple les noms de François Baroin
ou Xavier Bertrand par exemple ceux qui
semblent assez peu probable et dans son
propre camp il y a le ministre des
Armées Sébastien Lecornu en ce moment il
est au banc pour sa loi de programmation
militaire et il présente l'avantage de
pouvoir nouer des accords avec la droite
dont il est issu et la toux aussi d'être
très appréciée du président et de ne pas
rêver tous les matins de prendre sa
place bon Sébastien pourrait être un
recours ce serait pas le seul évidemment
en allonge la liste encore et si le
président ne souhaite ni un Premier
ministre qui lui fasse de l'ombre ni
former une coalition avec la droite il
lui reste c'est fidèle parmi les fidèles
et là on a Julien de Normandie qu'on
appelle le chouchou du chef de l'État
c'est un macroniste historique une tête
bien faite plus technicien que politique
un peu similaire d'ailleurs à Elisabeth
borne ou encore Richard Ferrand l'ancien
président de l'Assemblée alors qui a
perdu son siège au législatif au mois de
juin mais qui reste une figure tutélaire
de la majorité et qui a beaucoup de
savoir-faire politique reste que pour
tout président changer de Premier
ministre ça reste toujours un casse-tête
et un problème et donc sans solution
évidente sans recours naturel on l'a
longuement expliqué Emmanuel Macron
pourrait être tenté une nouvelle fois de
procrastiner ce qui octroie et Elisabeth
borne de beaux jours devant elle rue de
Waremme effectivement merci Mathilde
Bérengère si on parle un peu de de des
idées du corpus idéologique d'Elizabeth
borne elle va vous dire il y a quoi les
macronistes elle est puisque elle vient
de la fin elle vient de la gauche est-ce
qu'elle a pris sa carte du parti
socialiste elle a jamais eu sa carte du
parti socialiste c'est une pure
macroniste pour moi c'est peut-être la
Philippe Grangeon qui qui est un des
meilleure connaisseur de cette macronie
me disait c'est c'est la plus macroniste
de toutes parce que elle a elle a pas eu
d'adhésion forte à la gauche au PS elle
a un corpus de valeur qui sont notamment
liées à son histoire personnelle je
pense
et puis ensuite elle a elle s'est
retrouvée avec Jospin qui est un et là
il y a une adhésion à l'homme elle est à
Matignon sous-jaspin elle est sa
conseillère elle est très proche ils
sont en grande confiance mais c'est plus
à l'homme à sa rigueur à sa droiture à
ça voilà c'est c'est l'ingénieur
bosseuse etc qui qui qui cadre bien moi
elle me parle du du
dogmatisme des 35 heures quand même
aujourd'hui donc moi je me dis mais vous
pensiez ça à l'époque
surtout pas qu'on lui dise qu'elle est
retourné sa veste mais non non j'ai
évolué mais et elle explique si j'ai
bien compris sa pensée que que en gros
le collectif c'est très bien oui c'est
important mais donc encore une fois il y
a vraiment ça quand même mais mais faut
pas que ça
ça dispense de de se prendre en main de
voilà il y a un mélange comme ça en
permanence qui à mon avis il y a un truc
qui va être très intéressant à observer
c'est justement le texte d'immigration
dont on parlait là en terme d'idéologie
en termes de positionnement je ne vois
pas comment elle peut valider un texte
trop dur ce sera enfin vous avez
souligné son élasticité ça va jusqu'à un
certain point je ne vois pas comment
elle peut ou alors ça va être
intéressant j'entends ce que vous dites
une difficulté à l'échelle parlementaire
mais peut-être une moins de difficulté à
l'échelle de l'opinion publique quand on
se souvient que Gérard Collomb et les
propositions sur l'immigration avait été
soutenues par les Français parce que
dans un contexte où quand le projet de
loi va être présenté s'il est présenté
sous quel format il y a quand même
beaucoup d'incertitudes la gauche
parlera de de projets liberticides voire
raciste la droite et à droite extrême
jugeront que le projet ne va pas assez
loin et de ce point de vue là la
macronie la majorité pour être un point
d'équilibre c'est ce qui avait bénéficié
à Gérard Collomb dans l'opinion je parle
pas de la scène parlementaires mais
c'est vrai que sur ce sujet compliqué
sur ce sujet qui n'est pas la
préoccupation majeure des Français mais
bien sûr elle existe elle est réelle pas
sur la thématique de la submersion mais
sur la thématique de la perte d'autorité
de l'État qui maîtrise plus ces
frontières l'État qui est plus capable
de garder les 200 réfugiés les 200
migrants de l'Aquarius etc c'est un
sujet qui peut être assez compliqué mais
moins compliqué que d'autres sur les
questions d'opinion moins que
l'inflation pour l'achat ou vraiment il
y a une attente ardente de l'opinion et
puis c'est pas si simple pour le parti
LR aussi qui avait affiché ces divisions
à l'occasion de la réforme des retraites
donc là ils vont aussi être au deuxième
j'enterrerai pas la possibilité d'une
alliance autour de ce texte trop vite
emilya pas
ça veut dire maintenant est-ce que c'est
la méthode est-ce que c'est la marche
forcée
c'est la question parce que ça veut dire
que moi je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous je pense que tout ce qui va
attirer trop à l'extrême droite ça va
être très compliqué enfin une droite dur
dans le texte immigration ça va être
très compliqué pour elle d'avaler ses
couleurs là je pense qu'elle en a déjà
avalé je pense qu'elle est pragmatique
et qu'elle avance elle sait faire
assurance chômage des réformes assez dur
ça ça va être compliqué mais qu'est-ce
que c'est par exemple quand un Sacha
oudier s'oppose à ça est-ce qu'il est
macroniste ou pas en fait je n'arrive
pas à voir au-delà de cette méthode qui
veut se passer globalement des corps
intermédiaires qui veut décider et faire
appliquer dès qu'ils ont une idée plutôt
prolibérale pro et qui tire de plus en
plus à droite mais qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'être macroniste elle est dans la
méthode mais elle n'est pas dans les
valeurs et globalement ces valeurs elles
ne sont pas toutes partagées la colonne
vertébrale c'est Emmanuel Macron ça va
être intéressant en 2027
pas très cohérent sur la laïcité sur
tous ces sujets là il est même pas très
Macron
sur beaucoup de sujets il nous reste
deux trois minutes sur le le bal des
prétendants quand même c'est ce que vous
nous parce que là la liste elle était
longue vous imaginez tous ceux qui
enlèvent est-ce que c'est pas aussi
lié à une fragilité d'Elizabeth
c'est-à-dire que le fait qu'on soit
finalement nous alors nous journalisme
évidemment ça nous passionne et
peut-être que vous nous l'avez dit
l'opinion française bon ça passe loin
des radars mais ça attise les ambitions
cette cette situation et donc peut-être
la tentation de jouer cavalier seul de
la part de cette impression de quelque
chose le recadrage le vrai faux
recadrage a eu un effet selon moi
inexistant sur l'opinion mais réel sur
un microcosme fragilise vous êtes borne
c'est vrai que les Français sont pas sur
une logique de casting mais sur une
logique de résultats et n'oublions pas
qu'il y a un il y a un ingrédient
absolument fondamental pour un président
quand il veut remanier petit large ou
total en changeant près de ma vie c'est
la surprise
de la Cinquième République c'est souvent
des premiers ministres que personne
n'avait vu voir où des bails des beaux
qui ont été prolongés personne imaginait
François Fillon passait l'échéance 2010
la réforme des retraites il est resté 50
donc voilà beaucoup de prudence
là-dessus donc vous pariez sur Isabelle
borne à Matignon à la rentrée
franchement ils n'ont ils n'ont pas de
majorité c'est donc ils peuvent en
changer dix fois après le gouvernement
peut aussi être renversé c'est-à-dire
que voilà avec un automne budgétaire
très difficile
d'émotions de censure pas sur puis vous
savez pas
que vous avez
cibler comme procrastinateur je je et ça
viendra peut-être de l'extérieur merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat je vais rappeler Bérengère le
titre de votre livre Elisabeth borne la
secrète aux éditions de l'archipel elle
avait la première ministre demandé la
suppression de certains passages ce sera
jugé fin juin c'est ça c'est en cours
merci d'être venu nous parler de votre
livre d'Elisabeth borne